foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight up is broken our sense that
she's the labor MP who's been vilified
abused and smeared as a Tran phob for
defending women's rights and I actually
talk to me exclusively and her first
interviews is being heckled by her own
labor party colleagues in Parliament
well Labor's odds on to be the next
party of government but Rosie Duffield
says there's a major problem with women
could that block secure stana's path to
power or debate
that's a story just too good to be true
but actually is true and that's the only
thing about it that is true because it's
about the biggest liar in political
history
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening welcome to
Piers Morgan on census standing up for
women's rights used to mean fighting for
Equal Pay equal opportunities and equal
respect now it means fighting for the
very word woman itself to even exist
birthing people menstruators bodies with
vaginas individuals with a cervix chest
feeders womens remix we're walks we're
Minx how do you even say those words
these are all terms used to describe an
adult human female everyone from the
British Health Service to the former
first lady of the United States Michelle
Obama let's be clear the Cambridge
dictionary dictionary now says an adult
human female is actually an adult who
lives and identifies as female that they
may have been said to be a different sex
at Birth
do you know this week the government of
Jersey launched a public health campaign
aimed at women which said if you are a
transgender man a gender non-conforming
person or a signed female at Birth and
with a cervix you can book your free
cervical screening today what about
women
in Jersey
what happens to them
why have they been airbrushed from all
these communications
the Brit award surrendered to a
ridiculous Crusade by going
gender-neutral I warned that messianists
would bet backfire and would just lead
to probably all male shortlist yeah well
guess what happened the best artist
category of the year is all male
nominees
I could have told them that because I
did tell them that
there's an Insidious campaign
to protect the very tiny percentage of
the population who identify as
transgender by erasing half of the
world's population who identify as women
and make no mistake it's a dirty
campaign
that's an elected representative of the
Scottish Parliament using rather
unparliamentary language to describe
women who've argued against the S P's
gender bill and the same rally last week
protesters waved science saying
decapitate turfs now Turf stands for
Trans exclusionary radical feminists
it's really just a smear word used
against any woman who dares to stand up
for women's rights so these be quite
kind equality angels are literally
calling for women to be beheaded is a
term for that too it's hate speech and
anyone who dares to call it out is
branded transphobic but it's not
transphobic to say that trans women born
to male bodies cannot fairly compete
against female athletes it's not
transphobic to say that women have a
right to feel uncomfortable about
transitioning men being in their
changing rooms and safe spaces it's not
transphobia to think it's utterly
terrifying that a muscle-bound
shaven-headed male rapist can change
gender after committing the most heinous
crimes against women and then be sent to
a female prison
Adam Graham Savage you raped two women
he met online when he first appeared in
court in 2019 he did so as a man
by the start of his trial he was now
apparently a woman now she is heading to
a woman's prison full of the kind of
women that he raped
it's almost Beyond parody this but it's
happening
and it's happening in Scotland where the
SMP wants anyone age 16 to be able to
self-identify as the opposite sex with
no medical diagnosis whatsoever
well very few people have had the
courage to speak out about this but one
of them one of the more notable people
is labor MP Rosie Duffield who did speak
out about it
the bill clearly conflicts with the
equality act and would have
repercussions for women for women across
the UK and given the previous uq just
doesn't have to have vitally important
this is at the moment
quite extraordinary scenes Rosie
Duffield there being heckled by her own
labor colleagues for a speech in which
she defends women's rights to safety
she's faced these ridiculous allegations
of transphobia for years and ironically
it all began when she liked this tweet
by me and I was responding to a
ludicrous tweet from my former employers
at CNN where they just wouldn't say the
word woman
and I said surely you're talking about
women not individuals with cervixes
about a cervical cancer screening story
and Rosie Duffield liked it
and for that all hell broke loose and
she got abused so badly it had so many
death threats she had to temporarily
come off Twitter
she's not a trans folk I'm not a
transphobe as I've said many times I
believe trans people deserve rights and
respect like everybody else
but I believe passionately in women's
rights and protecting those too and so
does Rosie Duffield I'm glad to say she
now joins me
well welcome
[Laughter]
um I mean that's quite an intro when you
read it all out isn't it yeah and you've
been at the center of this storm and can
I start by apologizing for the Tweet
which you liked which entered you into
this Bear Pit of Mayhem let's go back to
that because I read this this tweet from
CNN in which they should be going out of
their way to cover a story about a
cervical cancer screening report in
which they were trying not to use the
word woman an individual with a surveys
and I thought this is preposterous yeah
you're talking about women aren't you
you liked it and then you followed up
and said actually I I just think women
have cervixes yeah absolutely and then
what happened uh and then I got all
kinds of like you said all hell broke
loose I mean I thought it was a good way
a sort of safe way to kind of put my
opinions out there and the opinions of
all of the women that I spoke to all of
the time who were asking someone to say
something about this you like you you
did a tweet and I thought okay I like
that it's just a tentative kind of toe
in the water and it was kind of amusing
what you were saying and you know it was
a stupid issue it was funny it was so
ridiculous like you said and then the
people that started sort of calling from
my beheading you know metaphorically
um
there is that as well but but you know
people calling for me to lose the whip
in the party are all the sort of people
that were running or leading labor
societies and that's where we've got the
problem in the party I think so you get
all this abuse so bad you end up
temporarily coming off Twitter because
it was so vile but what is even more
shocking to me is that your own labor
party colleagues from the top down
basically threw you to the walls yeah
they didn't want to go there this is too
toxic yeah they couldn't even say what a
woman is in fact it's against armor your
boss at labor party
um he was asked directly whether a woman
had a penis by Ferrari listen to this
a woman can have a penis
Nick I'm not but
I don't think we can conduct this debate
with
you know sorry I'll get this indigenous
no no it's just no no I just is it
transphobic to say only women have a
cervix well it is uh something that uh
shouldn't be said it is not right but
Andrew I don't think that the rosie
Duffield should not have said that can
you explain to people watching why she
should not have said that well Andrew I
don't think that
um we can just go through various things
that people said
I found it extraordinary I mean I like
hairstyle I get on very well with him
with fellow Arsenal fans it's a good
time to be an Arsenal fan I gotta say on
this he's really LED himself and the
party down because you've got to be able
to say what a woman is if you want to
lead a political party absolutely it's
not difficult it's an adult female but
more people in this country are women
and women will knock on doors campaign
donate to parties and vote and if women
don't feel that we're represented that's
a serious State of Affairs politically
and I had met with Keir I think the aide
who talked about me so that I was always
always in and out of his office I met
with him once well Matthew Doyle
all the time yeah I met him once and I
mean let's actually play The Clue this
was leaked by Guido Forks the media
website let's listen to what he actually
said Matthew door
foreign
[Music]
on behalf of Kia stama and there he is
actively briefing against you as it
turns out lying about the number of
times you've seen kirstan he said you're
in and out all the time and mocking you
for not spending enough time in your
Canterbury constituency saying you're
spending too much time with JK Rowling
yeah I mean I've never met this man I
have no idea how he thinks he knows
those things how many times have you
been in kirst Armor's office I was there
the week before he gave that interview
to Andrew Ma and I was trying to explain
my point of view I was trying to explain
that lots of women's groups were in
touch with me that I had had nearly 400
Bunches of flowers and cards and emails
and they never stopped they haven't I've
not met a woman
who would disagree with you I've not met
one I don't know where they exist these
people yeah but I have not met a woman
and I've traveled far and wide in the
last two years I've not met a single
woman who looks me in the eye privately
and says well it's all ridiculous of
course we know what a woman is there are
a few labor MPS there are a few right I
know they exist because I see the hell
that you have to go through but just to
be clear on Kia Starman how many times
have you been in his office since then
uh not once not once no so this is
complete nonsense being skewed too but
this guy doesn't know me doesn't know
anything about me but it's a very clever
line isn't it I I knew I'd heard that
they've been briefing about me before
this but of course I had no proof it was
just this kind of feeling that you know
I knew that they weren't pleased with my
stance on things but to hear him I mean
that's so clever to start sowing the
seeds of Doubt oh maybe she's not in her
constituency and then it gets through to
my what's the truth about that of course
I'm there every single week like every
other MP you know I live there I've
lived there since 1999 how many times
have you seen Jay care running
personally in the last two years I saw
at Christmas so the Famous Lunch yeah
that was another look that was okay
you've seen it a couple of times yeah
and we took most days actually so you're
not spending most weekends up in
Scotland plotting that would be lovely
but no I'm at home in Canterbury and
we're going to come to her in a moment
on Kirsten though when you when you saw
him what did you say to him
um I just explained the situation I said
I'm so sorry the story at the time was
that I wasn't going to conference
because of all the death threats I was
so embarrassed by that story getting out
there I hadn't said I hadn't announced I
wasn't going to I told a couple of
friends that I thought it was a good
idea not to go it was his first big
speech I didn't want to be the headline
ironically I was the headline for about
three weeks yeah about that and uh so I
said to him you know we've got into this
situation will he meet with these groups
will you hear what I've got to say and
he was really sympathetic he said oh I
haven't heard of this group labor
women's declaration 8 000 signatures to
say that they want this to be discussed
they want people to to talk about it
freely and since then a couple of
conferences have passed and labor
women's declaration are not even allowed
to have a stall at neighborhood and then
you know a few days ago we see you being
openly mocked and jeered by your own
side in the comments yeah for standing
up for women's safety I mean Ben
Bradshaw was one and who was the other
there was another male member right yeah
uh let's just see a little bit of this
Bill clearly conflicts with the equality
act and would have repercussions for
women for women across the UK and given
the previous uq does do you not
understand how vitally important this is
at the moment
quite extremely two male labor MPS yeah
Lloyd Russell Moyle and Ben Bradshaw a
former Minister he was heard shouting
absolute rubbish yeah as you defended
beneath the spaces segregated by sex
yeah how have we got to misplace Rosie
where what seems to me to be just the
obvious Common Sense thing to do is
being eradicated at the altar of
political correctness I think it's
activists I think it's the kind of
people if you are based in London and
you're leading a party where you know
your staff and all your associations and
labor societies are the same kind of
people we're very nepotistic party I'm
finding out I guess the others are as
well I don't I can't speak on that but
you're surrounded by the same people the
same activists the same people are on
the NEC or the boards of this that and
the other you're just hearing the same
voice when you see the leader of the
party secures Dharma unable to say
whether people with penises are women
what was your reaction I
dice really I mean it
can I don't know what to make of it half
the time it sort of seems funny half the
time it's really scary I mean high
profile women Dame Joan Collins was one
a great friend of mine who didn't want
to say what she thought a woman was
anymore because didn't want to get the
aggro that would come from answering the
question that's what we've got to where
some of those glamorous women of all
time like Joan just feel that they've
been cowed by the mall really sad and
they don't want to go into that Bear Pit
that you've gone into you know how vile
it can be but I have to because I have
hundreds of thousands of women
contacting me and I'm involved in lots
of women's groups and I know how they
feel and I think with a party of Working
Class People and working class women
those are Our Roots the kind of people
that are likely to be in the kind of
prison that you talked about at the
start of the show a working class women
that's our job and I will continue I
mean that story of the of the man who
raped two women yeah and tonight his
ex-wife or her ex-wife has now broken
her silence and apparently she thinks
he's scamming everybody is a man just
using this as an excuse to get into
women's prison which is why his rights
as a rapist are something we're talking
about anyway right you know that is
absolutely agree let's take a short
break Rosie after the break I want to
talk about your friend JK Rowling is who
tweeted this Rosie Duffield an
ex-assistant teacher single mother
survivor of domestic abuse one labor a
seat they thought was unwinnable post
Corbin she was returned upon an
increased majority and this is how labor
repays that let's discuss that after the
break
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
my special guest Rosie Darfield labor MP
so Rosie your friendship with JK Rowling
I mean you're joined I guess by this
issue in a sense that she she was very
supportive of you publicly because she
could see the hell you were going
through she's gone through similar stuff
for expressing similar views of trying
to support women's rights to safety and
and so on
tell me about JK and your friendship
um she's my
she's much and very very funny we all
kind of we've got to sort of you know
groups we've got
a DM group
want to kind of keep each other going
really on a daily basis people like
Julie bindle and me well there's a funny
picture actually because I think you and
Julie Bendel uh you were with her and
you wore a t-shirt with you and Jake
here running as dinosaurs after David
Lammy yeah Labor uh Shadow Minister
called turfs dinosaurs that was the gift
that really kept on giving because you
know I've been sent dinosaur jewelry
dinosaur chocolate
what do you what I mean what
the wide labor party have responded
it seems to me they're siding with
people who are waging an Insidious war
against women's rights so what does it
say about them from secure downwards I
think it is fear I think all of it is
fear yeah I think
I think we've got so many very senior
men so the Chiefs of Staff the general
secretary Kia himself you know all this
head of comms whatever it is he does
they're all men they're all men based in
London I don't think that they're
listening to people I don't think
they're hearing people what's your
message to kirst armor tonight if he's
watching this I think I'd like him to to
listen to women's groups I'd like to to
know that he's met with those people
that are really concerned about should
he should he listen to you I mean should
you not that would be nice if you want
to have a definition of a woman are you
the person he should go to could you
help him I'm a particular expert in that
but it would be nice too you know what I
want is because you are one I thought I
did yeah it'd be nice if we just had a
dialogue you know he's my colleague and
we're we're there and one of the pledges
he told us when he was signing for
leadership was as someone who'd employed
thousands of people his door was always
open and
you know it'd be nice if we could just
just go in have you tried to see him
again
um I've messaged him a few times and
when I've had particular particularly
terrible abuse it got really really bad
about a year or so ago and he did phone
me and say he was sorry but I think he
feels very limited as to what he can do
he won't for example show public support
he or why uh
I guess all of the pressure from all of
the labor student groups and the labor
activists and most of them are but do
you think he believes himself I've got
no idea he's never given you any
indication no I don't know I don't know
what he thinks really
you're in a place where the labor party
look should be roaring to a pretty
comfortable beach in the next election
but this women's issue isn't going away
it's kind of ripping large parts of the
party apart in many ways yeah and I
don't want that of course I don't want
that but in 2019 I remember telling a
few people possibly care I don't know
but in 2019 there were two things on the
Dual step for me in Canterbury brexit
Jeremy corbyn and anti-Semitism in the
same sentence and it was very hard to to
win as an MP in 2019 as a labor MP as
you know the third thing that came up
was women taking me aside and asking to
tell me about their experiences one was
a social worker one was a teacher one
was just a mum and it was before way
before your Tweet before I said anything
in public and I took them aside and I
listened to them so I knew this is not
going away but when I tried to mention
it I was told to colleagues even I was
told it was a niche issue shouldn't be
talking about it we should be talking
about important things and big issues
when you saw for example I mean it seems
to me there's a lot of fronts the attack
is coming from at the moment the Brit
Awards with the gender neutrality issue
which many people like me warned at the
time would almost certainly lead to the
awards actually being skewed more to the
men we'd have the opposite effect to
what people thought it would have when
you saw all the male artists nominees
were men this year what did you think
pretty depressing isn't it I mean you
know lots of us were talking the women
who haven't talked about the gender
critical side of things and and the
trans side of things are all really
angry about that but you know that's the
face of all of this if you change our
language if we don't get to protect our
spaces this is kind of where we're going
but if we don't take the word woman and
we don't celebrate Womanhood and we
don't celebrate femininity and being
female what's wrong with a best female
artist category it's the trans Lobby
group wanted an award show have their
own or have their own category yeah I
don't mind if you know Sam Smith in one
minute he's a straight guy next minute
he's a gay guy next minute he wants us
to call him they them because he's
non-binary I don't give a damn what he
wants to call himself I do give a damn
when his campaigning means the brittle
walls decides to go gender-neutral and
the victims are women artists who've now
been completely evaporated from his
event really so gender neutral usually
means without women or women being
excluded so he's seen those signs on the
news that are tweeted and there's a
disabled sign and a woman's sign and a
unisex sign and then there's another
door and it's just got a man sign you
think hang on a sec and then you get to
sport which is even more depressing
because everybody knows how ridiculously
unfair this is everybody knows that just
reducing testosterone doesn't make any
difference post puberty to a man's body
mass his muscle his strength his lung
capacity I interviewed one of the
British champion shot Buddha last night
uh Amelia strickler and she was you know
really good actually we've got a little
clip I think of it from the interview
last night
I think we've got a clip of the
interview but she was great because she
she basically said look we're we're
going to end up I've got a hair now
they'll never have periods they'll never
experience that you know it it does
hinder many many females yes female
children it's a real issue even you know
Dino this summer said you know I've had
lady issues and she didn't perform well
when she didn't perform well that day
and you know it's understandable
I mean I hadn't even really thought
about that aspect but she's so right is
that trans women athletes don't have
that issue of a monthly period that they
have to deal with as athletes which can
be very debilitating if not performance
reducing as we just heard
um
again no thought given to this other
than we're going to get our way and we
don't care about women's rights here or
fairness and equality in their own
Stampede for what they see is fairness
and equality for their own Community the
trans Community they are creating a new
unfairness inequality absolutely My
friend Sharon Davis yeah I've spent a
lot of time
she's fantastic and she feels I think
I'm not putting words in her mouth I've
been to events where she's spoken that
what you know she missed out on a gold
medal partly because of the doping of
some of the Eastern European countries I
think she feels that she's reliving that
all over it we saw it with the New
Zealand weightlift female weightlifting
team where Laurel Hubbard who had
competed as a man before now got an
Olympic plays at the expense of a woman
born to a female body yeah that to me is
completely unfair Laurel Hubbard was
unsuccessful as a male competitor
actually and then suddenly as an
Olympian yeah as a woman and we've seen
it in cycling well there's a cricketer
down in kentouch it's six foot four inch
cricketer who was a male cricketer with
an average of 17 I think becomes a
female female cricketer and suddenly
averages 120. wow I was a cricket fan I
find that utterly ridiculous yeah I mean
it's just not fair like you said it's
not a level playing but if you say that
you're a transfer apparently no I mean
we've talked in sports and circles you
know I know some sports psychologists
who who are really talking about this
issue and what about different
categories because this argument is in
its infancy we haven't got there yet we
haven't found Solutions but the solution
isn't pushing women aside it can't be or
abusing women or threatening women I
mean these scenes we saw at the protest
about the Scottish gender recognition
bill which to me is a ridiculous bill
which allows 16 year olds they're not
allowed to buy a drink legally now
determine their lifetime gender without
any need for any medical diagnosis I
think it's crazy but people were
protesting about the UK government
protesting rightly about what's going on
up there and they were actually having
signs saying decapitate turfs you've
been named sort of Chief Turf along with
JK Rowling these people wanted and
they're trans activist wanted you and JK
running and people like you to be
decapitated yeah yeah what do you feel
about that
um it sounds weird but I'm sort of used
to it I mean all women MPS get them you
shouldn't be used to it
I shouldn't really but but it's really
disgusting kind of normal actually yeah
look I know it's been horrific for you I
can only apologize again for starting
all this because without my tweet which
you liked you might have been blissfully
carrying on as a below the radar MP
although I suppose to come out I suspect
you would have spoke about at some stage
but I think you're very gutsy for what
you do I think you should keep going
don't bow to the Mob We need more people
like you and JK Rowling and Amelia
strickler and people like this to speak
out on behalf of women women need to
speak out to save women's rights and men
need to do the same yeah
watching my invitation for you to come
on the program remains maybe tomorrow's
the key come and answer this charge I'll
tell you what a woman isn't a woman
doesn't have a penis it's really not
that hard it's a kid you want to run the
country you better get with the program
and it's a program it's been around
thousands of years unless we get
reaction to Rose's interview with
tonight's pack and debate what it means
to the party but could soon be running
our government if they stop trashing
women
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Petersburg Wisconsin
super lies keep coming for Pinocchio
politician George Santos the U.S
congressman now claiming he was a victim
and attempted assassination this is a
long list of lies that speed from his
mouth and he remains in Congress it's a
quite extraordinary story he's now
indispitably in my view the greatest
line of history of global politics and
Fox News is Captain for join me to
discuss this bizarre bizarre story a
little later but first to my exclusive
interview with labor MP Rosie Duffield
here's what she said about her leader
securestama's inability to Define what a
woman is
more people in this country are women
and women will knock on doors campaign
donate to parties and vote and if women
don't feel that we're represented that's
a serious State of Affairs politically
and I had met with Keir I think the aide
who talked about me so that I was always
always in the out of his office I met
with him once when you see the leader of
the party secures Dharma unable to say
whether people with penises are women
what was your reaction I
speechless really I mean it just seems
kind of mad you know it's dystopian I
don't know what to make of it half the
time it sort of seems funny half the
time it's really scary
well strong words there dystopian and
scary are more impact tonight to discuss
TV program to Kate McCann Daily Mirror
Associated to Kevin McGuire I've talked
to the contributor Esther kraku welcome
to all of you our Stella panel okay
I mean this is quite a damaging ongoing
problem for Securus Dharma and when you
have something like Rosie dufford who
clearly just calmly talked me through
what's happened to her after she
actually liked one of my tweets uh
mocking the sort of terrible use of
language about women these days
so here's Thomas you can't even Define
what a woman is you have a woman MP
being vilified shamed hounded and now
apparently just thrown to the Walls by
your party
it's damaging isn't it it's really
damaging and what Rosie Duffield was
saying to you about how there are a lot
of men in the labor party almost all of
the jobs at the top she listed them yeah
our men not just that but they're men
from London and the point she's making
is that there are lots of women around
the country who don't agree with that
point of view and who will vote for the
labor party and her point about you know
working-class women are more likely to
end up in some of these prisons where
there are questions about who else is
going to be in a prison with them that's
something she feels very strongly that
she's there to represent and I think the
fact that this week the Optics of of
what we saw in the House of Commons from
Lloyd Russell Moyle and other MPS and
the subsequent I mean it wasn't exactly
a deafening chorus of people coming to
her age well I think there have been I
mean I've written a column for the sun
tonight about this there have been four
things in one week yeah which I think
constitute Esther this ongoing war
against women won the Brit Awards having
this ludicrous decision to go
gender-neutral and then all the
nominations the best artist being male
an own goal a spectacular proportions
were women of the victims then you have
this shocking story of this transgender
rapist who actually was a man when he
did the raping then when he goes to
trial suddenly identifies as a woman and
it's not going to be transferred
apparently to a woman's prison well this
person I don't know what we legitimately
call this person because they well his
ex-wife has come out tonight in the
Daily Mail online and she was married to
him uh has no time for him at all but
says he's just pulling whatever this is
all Hashem she says it's a sham for
attention easier life in prison when I
saw photographs of him just as a woman
with a blonde wig and pink Leica
leggings I have a lot of bed laughing
the job is it's not actually funny
because he will now be this serial
rapist put into a woman's prison where
he will be around women he could
potentially assault well this is this is
this is and that's what Rosie does Jill
was talking about in Parliament safe
spaces for women when male labor MPS
hounded her yep I mean this is the real
misogyny and you notice how men don't
have this problem it's not men being
shouted down it's not men's spaces that
are being invaded it's not men being
told that their categories need to go
it's not men that are questioning
whether they're going to have trans men
you know prisoners in their prisons it's
always women and it's only women dealing
with this it's only women who Sports uh
you know categories are being completely
modeled now and we are bearing them the
other two things that have happened one
you've got Word athletics saying they're
not going to ban trans athletes and
women's sport just want a reduction
again in testosterone which has no
impact on body mass and so on and then
you have these horrific scenes up in
Scotland where protesters were actually
urging the decapitation of tests of
turfs who are basically any woman that
stands up to the ultra trans Lobby in
their demands for what actually
constitutes in my view a new unfairness
inequality but this is the patriarchy
this is the new form of the patriarchy
that we're fighting against because no
one else has to deal with this no one I
mean the fact that you know just
Phillips um in in the comments didn't
say anything didn't actually publicly
support
um her colleague but she's done so much
work with domestic violence victims that
have happened to be women it just shows
how far this madness has gone Kevin
what is what's wrong with kirst armor
here why can't he just come out and
support women the labor party is
supposed to be the Progressive Party
that is pro-women's right we can all see
there is an ongoing erosion both in the
way we talk about women the use of the
word woman itself women's rights in
sport in the sporting Arena and so on
these are pretty well unarguable things
that are going on why can't a little
labor party come out and defend even his
own MP who's being hounded like this I
think he's going to have to at some
point address the issue like in politics
any question you can do three things you
can confront it you can concede it or
you can change the conversation and at
the moment he's always seem to want to
change the conversation because you have
a conflict of Rights you have the rights
of women then you have the rights of
trans people particularly trans women
who say they were born essentially in
the wrong bodies that's what they say
you can't change your sex but you can
change it but I think as you can see to
me if I was reading a party hasn't it's
quite straightforward I want equality
and fairness to try trans people
unquestionably but not if it actually
infringes and damages existing women's
rights and I I agree with every word of
that but how is he was right I think
everyone I've met every woman I've met
honestly in the last two years agreed
with that yeah but they will approach it
differently now Rosie Duffield doesn't
speak for all women in labor look half
the shadow cabinet that the top team are
women more than half labor MPS
are women so there are a lot there are a
lot there are a lot there are a lot of
women in the Parliamentary labor party
and they will not all agree with the
tone and the approach of Rosie Duffield
but I agree there should be no
discriminant employment no discussions
very reasonable but very respectful but
there is the question remotely transfer
sport in women's places like changing
rooms refuges prisons these questions
that have to be addressed but in a way
it's probably the nastiest debate in
politics at the moment where people
screaming on both extreme it's also I
got to say I think okay it's the most
cowardly debate I mean labor all right
they have a male leader but next to him
in pmqs today Angela Rayner and Rachel
Reese two experienced senior female
politicians where are they honestly they
keep they all talk about women's rights
all the time here is one of their own
women being abused by male colleagues in
the House of Commons the standing up for
safe spaces for women in a week when a
multiple rapist is now being sent to a
woman's prison after raping two women
for a month segregation because he puts
his hand up and says I'm transitional
because his ex-wife says he's just
stabbing him repairs he's got he's been
sent for a month in segregation for
assessment why is he going there
by the way you're calling him you're
calling him he yeah I just said him I
mean the truth is his ex-wife thinks the
whole thing is a total if he wishes to
be addressed as there I'll call him
there but I because he's a rapist the
way he raped
but why why should I care yeah about
using the right pronoun for a multiple
rapist would you for his own ex-wife
yeah if you're going to conduct this
debate with respect then even though you
feel incredibly strongly about what that
person did and everybody will you do
have to afford them the same response I
don't agree well
why should I because I think because
I think this is the problem with this
debate and and this is where it gets
very tricky and and to drag it back to
the politics I found it fascinating
today that kirstrama at a point when the
prime minister is under incredible
pressure we were talking about Nadim
zahawi quitting half an hour before
we're watching pmqs that the labor
leader decided to use his first three
questions in pmqs to talk about Zara
Alina and he described the person who
murdered her as a woman hating Thug now
that that's something that he was very
happy to talk about yes and particularly
identify that I am against you know
women hating this crime is awful and I
think that's an indication that labor
does know it has a problem but it
doesn't yet know how to solve it because
there's a lot of hatred being spewed
about Rosie Duffield who is standing up
for women's safety which is the very
issue he led on in pmqs when he probably
should have gone for Nadeem zahawi but
if you're going to make your issue
women's safety and women's rights why
are you throwing to the walls one of
your own MPS because who have literally
been terrorized and had death threats
because I think I think it's I think for
political parties and maybe for lots of
people watching this it's a deeply
uncomfortable and difficult issue and
and people don't always know how they
feel about it and they don't always feel
comfortable articulating it in case they
get something wrong that's the part of
the problem is I think there's a kind of
terrorism that goes with this trans
debate where anyone who dares to
challenge any of it gets immediately
targeted in the most hateful way whether
it's JK Rowling me if I did when I did
my things yeah and he comes back to it's
interesting debate so Kate says look if
you're going to have a reasonable debate
about this even if it's a multiple
rapist we should respect their choice of
pronouns to which my response is I've
just read this interview with this
person's ex-wife who says this whole
gender transition is a sham for
attention and easier life in prison I'm
damned if I'm going to respect his
personal if he's just a scam to avoid
Justice it's a sham then exactly then
the processes how do you prove
somebody's not actually wanting to be a
woman then the processes that we have in
place to ensure that somebody who is
Faking It should pick that up
okay that's not right because the
process at the moment is allowing a
rapist a male rapist of women simply
because they've said I'm now turning
into a woman okay you go to a woman's
prison where there may be more targets
for you now
in segregation for him
why are we dedicating State resources to
this with all due respect I don't think
the gender identity of prisoners should
matter your crime is what you're being
punished for there are two prisons male
and female your gender identity doesn't
come into this well I gotta says you
have that separation it does matter
you're not going to say I'm full I'm far
more concerned about respect for Rosie
Duffer which he's not getting from her
own party and leader than I am about
respecting personal pronouns from
multiple rapists he can frankly swing
for it uh anyway we'll come back with
something a little later after the break
because tonight more outrageous lies
from the man is already the biggest lie
in political history when you think
about all the great Liars in politics
around the world in perpetuity for
history is quite an achievement cat Tim
from Fox News joins me to discuss if
anything if anything if any lie will be
too much but Congressman George Santos
to survived
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ERS in politics we know that but nobody
quite reaches the dizzying heights of
U.S congressman George Santos a
republican who literally doesn't even
tell the truth about his own name he's
used about eight pseudonyms so we
thought we'd have a bit of fun with Mr
Santos tonight by playing a game of
would I lie to you
foreign
[Music]
America will be watching and observing
ready to pounce on Santos at the end of
this so let's start the wood I lie to
your game by pretending for a moment I
am George Santos
the first question I survived an
assassination attempt
false it is indeed completely untrue no
proof of that whatsoever number two my
mother died on 9 11 in the Twin Towers
but he did say it uh he did say it but
it's completely untrue it never happened
in fact his mother died I'm George
Santos so I said it uh my mother
actually died in 2016 there's no record
of her ever having worked in the Twin
Towers number three my grandmother was a
victim of the Holocaust and I'm Jewish
uh that's false that is also completely
untrue is there a record of him either
being Jewish or any of his family ever
being involved in the Holocaust number
four I could have been a professional
basketball player but I chose Elite
Volleyball because it was easier
yeah
he played volleyball at any level
whatsoever and didn't even go to college
at number five I absolutely did not
steal my ex-roommate's Burberry scarf
and later wear it at a stop the steel
rally
number six I own 13 properties and a
sprawling real estate Empire Falls
unless they're sheds yeah completely uh
I own no properties and I live with my
sister number seven I saved thousands of
dogs lives by running an animal charity
whatsoever in fact he's accused of
swindling a disabled vet whose dog is
dying and finally I wasn't a Brazilian
drag queen
he was that's false false I'd have a lie
as a drag queen in Brazil so there we
have it let's go to Captain we've been
waiting patiently cat I have I have
never encountered a greater liar I don't
think in the world than George Santos
which prompts the question how is he
still a serving congressman
yeah well I think that's probably
because if there was a lot of pressure
for politicians to resign over lying
there would be no one left uh like you
said they all do it but usually I think
what politicians the kind of lying that
they're involved in is more hypocrisy or
things that might sort of help their
career or there's some sort of
discernible reason for why they would
have lied about something not that it's
okay of course but as opposed to lying
about for example as you mentioned being
a volleyball star at a college when you
didn't play volleyball nor go to that
college that doesn't affect your life
either way there's something so could he
this man should be studied because it
makes no sense well it's I mean
obviously it's a weird form of he's like
a sociopath meets a narcissist I mean I
just I've never encountered anyone who's
so Brazen about it even in public
documents which he's released to
potential voters up there is all this
stuff as if it's all true he names all
the schools he went to the universities
all of it is completely invented there's
no record of any of this stuff
right or the stuff whether it took him
forever to admit that it was him dressed
up in drag yeah he's still denying it
even when there was a photo of him which
by the way I I actually think he was not
a queen because he was not good at his
makeup there was no contouring done or
anything so you could tell it was his
face okay and he still was like I would
never the media well there he is I mean
it's like I mean it is a little cracker
isn't he um
even then he was like on Twitter it is
categorically untrue I have ever been a
drag queen in Brazil and I I said to
somebody on the show I said you know
what's the only cast iron certainty is
that within 24 hours there will be a
picture to prove he was and sure enough
within 24 hours there was a picture of
George Santos as a drag queen in Brazil
yeah absolutely I don't understand it I
I who is this guy you know it's that
what does he do for example on the
weekend what is a typical weekend look
for this guy who are his friends we I I
just I'm so so fascinated by that
because this is like nothing I've ever
seen he doesn't even call himself he
doesn't even call himself George Santos
until very recently he calls himself all
sorts of pseudonyms he's been using an
aliasis So when you say who is this guy
he's not even who we think he is George
Santos is what the name he's given
himself in the last like year and a half
yeah I know I I look I I would really
like to get to know this person and I
said this also I think he might be a
great friend because you can trust him
with all your secrets because if he told
everybody your secrets no they won't
believe it
I mean panel here I mean it is
astonishing the scale of this is the
British politician who had lied on this
Monumental scale he'd be long gone or
she'd be long gone by now and yet he
hangs on because the Republicans have a
very tenuous hold on the House of
Representatives so there's a political
motivation I survive it's not getting
rid of him but where have we got to in
the world of politics globally where
political expediency means you will
literally tolerate a sitting congressman
who is who was told literally 30 40
Whoppers they've always been Liars uh
look Donald Trump himself The Washington
Post said he lied 20 000 times in his
presidency but this this guy is almost
like the laboratory love child of trump
and Boris Johnson
where he was born or the jobs
but the thing is I'm surprised the
Republican party doesn't have the
apparatus to actually do a background
search on the people that they they put
up as as candidates that's what's
incredible I don't think they can
because I think they thought yeah I
think they fell in the in the it was the
Third District in New York they just
felt he had the best chance of beating
the Democrat they just didn't care and
he supported the big Trump lie they did
the election stolen and so on I mean
Kate do we have a fundamentally a
massively bigger problem now with
political veracity than we've ever had
before I feel we do I feel like Trump
and Boris Johnson these guys they
changed the game for public
dependency on truth that they just lied
so often that people have just stopped
worrying whether politician's life
doesn't matter as much I think I don't
think people have stopped worrying about
it but I wonder if something has been
eroded Slowly by what's happened in
politics here and and in America
actually you can see the evidence of
that and some of the lies here I mean I
wonder even though I think they've stuck
him on two congressional committees now
I wonder whether now we've got to the
money because I think he's he declared
it made a six hundred thousand dollar
donation to himself and now he says
actually I didn't pay that money I don't
really know where it came from when it
comes to money I mean that's a different
story they might the Republicans might
find that harder to swallow yeah but
yeah I do wonder about that and
particularly in the conversation around
Nadeem zahawi you know lots of people
are asking well who knew about this when
did they know yeah and why did no one
ask the questions and I wonder whether
that's part of the problem too not
really wanting to know anymore yeah cat
I mean what's the view in America about
this because I I can't imagine there
aren't a lot of Republicans who feel
deeply uncomfortable about this guy and
just what a terrible liar he is
uh yeah I mean he's obviously a lot more
than just a bit of a laughing stock I
don't know anybody who is saying that
any of this stuff is cool or remotely
normal I think that another issue is
partisanship right as you sort of
alluded to I think that it's just it's
all people care about is their own team
and as long as he's on your team then
he'll want him in there and that goes
for both sides and I think that that
kind of breeds this kind of corruption
and lying which is why I've actually
never voted for either major party I
always vote third party libertarian but
the the vast majority of people are
Super Hyper party I totally agree it's
it's across both parties and it's really
it's out of control they've got to get a
grip of this truth does matter cat great
to talk to you thank you very much great
to see you pack whatever you're up to
tonight Keep It Uncensored that's it
good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign